leftists and conservatives battle over
MLK's legacy epa chief scott pruett is
in hot water and a Comedy Central
comedian says you are having too many
children I'm bettin Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all right so yesterday marked the
anniversary 50th anniversary of the
assassination of the Martin Luther King
and we'll be talking about that in just
a few minutes but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so right now have you been watching
the stock market because it is up and
down like a yo-yo it was down 700 points
earlier this week than it was back up
and then it was down again this is how
the stock market's been working lately
if this makes you feel a little insecure
about your asset base maybe you ought to
be thinking about investing a little bit
in precious metals Birch gold group has
a long-standing track record of
continued success they are the folks
that I trust with precious metals
investing if thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews in a
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group now to
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals in this
comprehensive 16 page kit shows how gold
and silver can protect your savings hey
can legally move that IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA to get that no cost no
obligation kit all you have to do is go
to birchgold.com slash pen that is
birchgold.com slash been again there's
no law in the books for the IRS that you
can actually move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
or silver and the folks at Birch gold
can tell you how birchgold.com slash
Bennett's birchgold.com slash men use
that slash Ben so that they know that we
say these are the folks that I would
trust when it comes to investing in
precious metals again because there are
so many others who trust them because I
know the folks over there I've talked
with them and you should ask all your
questions always before you invest in
precious metals but once you are ready
to do so call my friends over at Birch
gold and they will help you out
birchgold.com / Ben alright so yesterday
marks as you say the 49th 50th
anniversary of the what we're preparing
to commemorate the 50th anniversary of
the assassination of Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King and there's a big fight
underway over Martin Luther King
Junior's legacy now I have a great book
by Brad Meltzer that I read to my child
about Martin Luther King jr. and what
Martin Luther King jr. did for the
United States and what he did for the
black community inside the United States
when my daughter's favorite books she's
growing up with it because I think that
it is important for all children to know
about the legacy of dr. King but one of
the things that we tend to do in modern
politics is instead of remembering
people for the things that they are
actually remembered for we go back and
we book again we do have a
history we go back and we look again at
all the things they did in their life
and then we say well this is really what
we should be remembering so for example
George Washington father of our country
a great general first president that's
what we remember him for but revisionist
historians will go back and they will
look at at George Washington they will
say well he was a slave owner we should
talk about that because that's really
his legacy his real legacy is that he
was a slave owner same things happening
with Thomas Jefferson his legacy the
Declaration of Independence and his
involvement with the Constitutional
Convention right he's he's he has a
phenomenal phenomenal legacy Eve's third
President of the United States but now
their cause to remove his monument
specifically because parts of his legacy
were associated with slavery right he
was a lifelong slave owner yeah this
sort of logic has applied to everything
you see it even with Abraham Lincoln
where there's now an attempts going on
to go back and recast Abraham Lincoln as
a rabid racist because in some of his
writings he speaks in racist fashion
even though he was the great Emancipator
who ended slavery in the United States
through the Civil War and through the
Emancipation Proclamation well Martin
Luther King obviously doesn't have
anything quite that checkered
slave-owning
or racism in his past he does have some
things in his past that we have
conveniently overlooked obviously he was
personally kind of a shambles in terms
of his treatment of women for example
but what we really remember dr. King for
and why we celebrate dr. King and I'm
you know I'm blessed that I shared my
birthday with dr. King's day right
Martin Luther King Day is January 15th
that's my birthday
and I've always had a special fondness
for that fact but dr. King what we
really remember him for is his message
which was not Malcolm X's message so to
understand Martin Luther King's message
we have to do it in contrast to Malcolm
X prior to his conversion to actual
Islam and his call for peace before he
was assassinated by the the folks over
at the Nation of Islam to which
Democrats still pay homage which is just
an incredible thing right
the people who assassinated Malcolm X
are still going around claiming they did
in this Astin a Malcolm X and then heads
of the Democratic Party are meeting with
their leaders like Louis Farrakhan
should show you something about the
state of today's modern politics but
Malcolm X's message was black militancy
his message was black separatism at
least in his early days when you read
the Autobiography of Malcolm X and then
later he realized maybe we should look
for a more conciliatory message Spike
Lee's movie covers some of this ground
okay Martin Luther King's message was
very different his message was we all
have to come
they're around universal human rights
that apply to black people as well as
white people that the calls of the
founding fathers apply to black people
as well as white people like Booker T
Washington or like the or like Frederick
Douglass the call from Martin Luther
King was fully within the American
tradition America has certain rights
inalienable rights and these extend to
black people and to prevent black people
from exercising these rights is an act
of terrorism and active evil an act of
tyranny and this was his basic message
and that message of racial
reconciliation was why we honor dr. King
if he had been a racial separatist like
Malcolm X we would not be honoring dr.
King we would be we would be talking
about whether his legacy has helped
contribute to the constant racial
tensions in the country the reason that
Martin Luther King is considered such a
great figure is because of the racial
reconciliation so I mean we'll play it
because it isn't one of the great
speeches in American history this is was
his speech the I have a dream speech
from the Washington Mall man this is
because he spoke in these terms it was
it was obvious that Martin Luther King
was bound to be an American here
obviously his assassination was one of
the great tragedies in American history
because right on the verge of a civil
rights movement that was to essentially
bear his imprimatur he was killed right
as he even it's it's just a horrifying
horrifying story in any case President
Trump tried to pay homage to dr. Martin
Luther King on the 50th anniversary of
his assassination I and he spoke about
that he posted this on his Twitter
yesterday this of course caused a lot of
consternation 50 years ago dr. King was
cruelly taken from this world by an
assassin's bullet but the promise he
fought for could never be taken away his
words his deeds they live on forever and
the cause for which he gave his life
only gains strength and force and power
with the passage of time on this
cherished day we honor the memory of
Reverend King and we rededicate
ourselves to a glorious view
where every American from every walk of
life can live free from fear liberated
from hatred and uplifted by boundless
love for their fellow citizens okay now
so many people were upset about this
right Oh a lot of people were very upset
about about president Trump putting this
out because folks on the Left think that
President Trump is a racist and they're
unhappy with a lot of the racially
conflagration ax stings that that Trump
has said in the past going all the way
back to Charlottesville that the fact is
though that what Trump is actually
saying right separate the message from
the man who's saying it what he's saying
here is the great American perception
Martin Luther King so in the mood of
revisionist history what is absolutely
happening right now is that the left is
going back and they're looking at Martin
Luther King's entire legacy and again
Martin Luther King was economically a
socialist Martin Luther King was
somebody who did not really understand
economics particularly while Martin
Luther King was somebody who was who was
focused in on the supposedly burst
struggles of unions across the country
and so the left broadly has tried to
take the the great attachment we have
the Martin Luther King and extend it to
these other causes so for example
there's a piece today by Leonard Pitts
jr. who is a columnist syndicated
columnist in the Miami Herald where he
talks about where he talks about Martin
Luther King and he said he talked about
the assassination he says fear purchased
the gun delusion loaded it ignorance
adjusted the sight intolerance pulled
the trigger 50 years ago those forces
killed the man they have sought ever
since to kill the memory now you know
again I agree with with what killed the
man right there but that was an
individual assassin in a country that
was still replete with racism
we're now 50 years down the road the
idea that we've spent 50 years burying
Martin Luther King's memory is a bit
insulting to all of the history of the
United States subsequent to his
assassination but here is what Leonard
Pitts says and this again I think is the
attempt to recapture the legacy of
Martin Luther King and put him in the
radical camp so there can be a call
today for more radicalism in politics
particularly on the racial side he says
quote there's a myth some of us cherish
and it goes like this there used to be
racism in this country a distance in
benign a time about which it's best not
to talk and impolite to even recall then
Martin Luther King organized a boycott
led some marches and gave a speech about
a dream
and ever since equality has rained ok
that's obviously meant to be a
caricature and straw man obviously it's
not true we should be teach
at Jim Crow we should teach about
slavery we should teach about the legacy
of those things we should teach about
the entire civil rights movement
including the Civil Rights Act including
Dwight Eisenhower sending federal troops
down into the South in the mid-50s
including President Truman integrating
the military we should talk about the
long struggle for justice in this
country for black folks we should talk
about Martin Luther King and we should
talk about Malcolm X it was a complex
time with a lot of complex figures you
should talk about all those things but
there is no question that racism since
Martin Luther King's assassination has
depleted incredibly rapidly to the
lowest point in certainly American
history as of maybe seven or eight years
ago before Barack Obama was elected and
then Barack Obama started I believe
using intersectional politics as a
substitute for a unifying policy but
Leonard Pitts says this is a silly myth
because it ignores the reams of evidence
and towers of testimony proving that
racism continues to stunt blunt and take
the lives of people of color again this
is the point that folks on the Left want
to make they want to say that Martin
Luther King's legacy was a failure
essentially that Martin Luther King did
not succeed it wasn't that he was Moses
who goes up to the top of the mountain
and sees the promised land and then
perishes it was the Martin Luther King
dreamt of a promised land that we have
never reached that we are still
wandering in the wilderness somewhere
out here and then Martin Luther King's
legacy is basically that he says a bunch
of things that we have failed to take
him up on Pitt says it's an offensive
myth because it reduces came to an
anodyne figure harmless enough to be
embraced by conservatives who
conveniently forget that while he was
here they stood against everything he
stood for first of all that's not true
more Republicans than Democrats vote on
a percentage basis in the Congress voted
for the Civil Rights Act of 1964 then
Democrats Southern Democrats were the
ones who are standing in the way of
Martin Luther King during the Selma
marches and attempting to bludgeon him
and they were imprisoning him it was not
Republicans okay that was Democrats so
the idea that it was a bunch of
conservatives who were standing in the
way of Martin Luther King is not
historically accurate
it was conservatives in many cases who
are standing with dr. King right there
were there were liberals no question who
stood with Martin Luther King and there
were conservatives who stood with Martin
Luther King and to pretend otherwise
that is offensive and that is a
rewriting of history but Pitts continues
the forces that killed him used this
myth to kill our memory of the
provocative radical progressive prophet
and preacher that he was so successful
had they been that Glenn Beck with a
straight face
claim the mantle of King a few years ago
so successful and some people are
indignant when it is pointed out to them
that Colin Kaepernick is actually
following King's example so six
the King's youngest child Bernice
recently tweeted how someone told her
that her father didn't offend people
well I mean maybe his youngest child
knows Martin Luther King's legacy better
than like Leonard Pitts I might suggest
and using Colin Kaepernick as a as a
someone akin to Martin Luther King
that's an insult to Martin Luther King's
legacy Martin Luther King actually knew
of what he talked Martin Luther King
actually had a program for change Colin
Kaepernick was looking for publicity and
he got publicity I'm not saying that he
doesn't have a good heart for what he
thinks he is doing but Colin Kaepernick
kneeling for the anthem is something
that Martin Luther King never would have
done because Martin Luther King
understood that he was standing with
America's legacy not against America's
legacy that the the darkness in
America's history was an obstacle that
was thrown in the way of founding
ideology that it was not part and parcel
rooted in our DNA as Barack Obama was
fond of saying I have more on this I
want to talk about but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at zip
recruiter so zip recruiter is the place
for you to get the best employees you
need great people and you need a better
way to find them zip recruiter knows
there's a smarter way so they built a
platform that finds the right job
candidates for you they learn what
you're looking for they identify people
with the right experience and then they
invite them to apply to your job and
these invitations have revolutionized
how you can find your next hire in fact
80% of employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day and zip
recruiter does not stop there they even
spot like the strongest applications you
receive so you never miss a great match
the right candidates are out there and
zip recruiter is how you find them now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
freight which is pretty awesome right
now go to zip recruiters comm slash
daily wire that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter comm slash
daily wiring again you can now try zip
recruiter for free so go over there make
sure you have the best employees ensure
that your company is staffed up make
sure that you're not stuck with schlubs
like I am every morning I mean how many
of these people will replace my zip
recruiter they don't know they don't
know but if we they are zip recruiter
will be the place that we look sip
recruiter calm and slash daily wire
check it out again you can post for free
over there by using slash daily wire and
let them know that we sent you zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire ok
so to continue on with the with the
leftist revisionist history about why
America celebrates Martin Luther King
the revisionist history here is not that
Martin Luther King was they're not lying
about some of the revisionist history
right when I say revisionist history
don't mean that they are that they are
fibbing about what Martin Luther King
did I'm saying they're fibbing about why
Martin Luther King was a popular figure
right why Martin Luther King has a day
of his own in the United States so
Leonard Pitts again writing the
syndicated column about the real legacy
of Martin Luther King he says all of
this is foolishness but the foolishness
exists because we allow it to because we
failed to vote like we could teach eat
teach organize and agitate like we
should so 50 years after King was killed
police can still get away with murder
people working full-time jobs still
can't feed themselves we still take
necessities from the masses to give
luxuries to the classes our children are
still ground-up by unnecessary war
african-americans are still hot last
hired first fired still
disproportionately poor sick
undereducated and killed okay well
there's a lot to unpack there but not
every disparity as we will see and we'll
talk about in just a second is due to
discrimination in the United States but
Leonard Pitts is saying that because
there is still disparity that obviously
is a symptom of the same root cause that
Martin Luther King was fighting namely
deep American racism and then of course
Leonard Pitts drops what he considers
his ultimate rhetorical h-bomb also jeff
Sessions is Attorney General and Donald
Trump president okay to call Jeff
Sessions a racist is really absurd Jeff
Sessions prosecuted members of the KKK
and Donald Trump as president a that is
a direct response it really is a Dre I
don't think that that Trump has been
great on race I really don't but if I
haven't made that clear in the past but
see say that Donald Trump is is a cause
of racism rather than an effect of an
intersectional politics that has now
generated a blowback on the other side
of the aisle I think would be wildly
inaccurate it's not evidence of
deep-seated American racism it's
evidence that Americans are willing to
get tribal if they think the other side
of the political aisle gets tribal as
well Leonard Pitts concludes things are
not as awful as they once were
but less awful is not a synonym for good
so those of us who believe in social
justice not as abstract possibility but
it's critical necessity must reclaim the
lost memory of King and defend it with
adamantine will from those who would
smother it and myth not just because it
inspires but also because it impels and
he says that we have lingered in the
valley for too long again this is what
the left is trying to do they're trying
to say that King's vision was never
accomplished and the right is saying
large swathes of King's vision were
accomplished which is why we celebrate
him well imagine in 1969 if you'd said
that white kids across the America cross
the United States would be celebrating
dr. Martin Luther King that would be
seen as a great step toward the
ending of racism in America certainly
would be good evidence that racism in
America has wane the left doesn't see it
like that because they want to
promulgate the myth Americans is deeply
racist place so now I want to read you
an article by Jesse Jackson so Jesse
Jackson was at the assassination of
Martin Luther King is one of the folks
who was there and he obviously has
become a demagogic and terrible race
leader not only has he engaged in racism
of his own not only has he engaged in
anti-semitism not only as he personally
a mess not only is he corrupt beyond
measure but he is still proclaiming that
every problem that happens in the United
States is a reflection of racism so this
is the question is dr. Martin Luther
King's legacy a failure or is it a
success folks on the Left say it's a
failure because America failed dr.
Martin Luther King
so here is what Jesse Jackson writes in
the New York Times today as the nation
prepares to commemorate the 50th
anniversary of the assassination of
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. we
should dwell not merely on how dr. King
died but also on how he lived he
mobilized mass actions when a public
accommodations bill and the right to
vote he led the Montgomery bus boycott
and navigated police terror in
Birmingham he got us over the
blood-stained bridge in Selma and
survived the rocks and bottles in hatred
in Chicago he globalised our struggle to
end the Vietnam the war in Vietnam how
he lived is why he would is why he died
this again is Jesse Jackson as he sought
to move beyond desegregation and the
right to vote to focus his work on
economic justice anti-militarism and
human rights the system pushed back hard
in the last months of his life he was
attacked by the government the press
former allies in the military-industrial
complex even black Democrats turned
their backs on him when he challenged
the party support for the war in Vietnam
by the way he was wrong about that the
war in Vietnam was not a bad war that
was the right war it was just fought in
absolutely the wrong way and smothering
everything that dr. King did in genius
and wonder is I think also a disservice
to the fact that a lot of the stuff he
said was controversial right and the
Vietnam War is one of those things this
is a growing number of Americans had a
negative view of dr. King in the final
years of his life according to public
opinion polls a man of peace he died
violently a man of love he died hated by
many America loathes marchers but loves
martyrs the bullet in Memphis made dr.
King a martyr for the ages we owe it to
dr. King and to our children and
grandchildren to commemorate the man in
full a radical ecumenical anti-war
pro-immigrant and scholarly champion of
the poor who spent much more time
marching and going to jail for
liberation and justice than he ever
spent dreaming about it and then he
talks about you know
the various things that Martin Luther
King marched for some of which I think
were wonderful many of which were
incredible and some of which were
socialist I mean some of which were not
so great the point here is what is
America now 50 years let's do a quick
retrospective where is America now the
answer is some of the disparities in
America have not been removed but legal
disparities legal discrimination is not
a thing in the United States
okay legal is I'm talking about laws
that discriminate between blacks and
whites in the United States these are
illegal in the United States they're
barred by federal law they should have
been barred by the 14th amendments of
the Constitution is the truth and in
1871 18 1869 but in any case it took a
hundred years for that legacy to be
realized to pretend that Martin Luther
King is a failure in order to promote a
radical race agenda that suggests that
all disparity in the United States is
due to discrimination is to do a
disservice to dr. King's memory and more
importantly to do a disservice to the
United States that has embraced his
memory so here is a better article on
the legacy of Martin Luther King this
one is from Jason Reilly another
columnist he is black from he's a black
guy who writes for The Wall Street
Journal he's on the editorial board
there he says after Martin Luther King
jr. was shot dead 50 years ago as he
stood on the balcony of a motel in
Memphis Tennessee riots broke out in
more than a hundred cities there were
also reports of violence on college
campuses and even on military bases
overseas where some black soldiers
refused to report for duty federal
troops were sent to Baltimore in Chicago
Mayor Richard Daley ordered police to
shoot to kill arsonists and shoot to
maim looters in Washington so many fires
were set you couldn't see the US Capitol
because of all the smoke general william
Westmoreland who commanded US forces in
Vietnam and happened to be in Washington
at the time said the unrest had left the
nation's capital looking worse than
Saigon did at the height of the Tet
Offensive President LBJ responded by
convening a meeting of the nation's most
prominent black activists and the invite
list is instructive and included a
philip randolph who led the fight to
desegregate the military Whitney Young
head of the National Urban League Roy
Wilkins leader of the n-double a-c-p
and Bayard Rustin a top adviser to King
who had helped organize the seminal 1955
bus boycott in Montgomery Alabama and
the 1963 march on Washington it almost
goes without saying that the leading
civil rights organizations today can no
longer count people of that caliber in
their ranks which may be the clearest
indication yet that the movement is over
and that the right side prevailed
if black Americans were still faced with
legitimate threats to civil rights such
as legal discrimination
or voter disenfranchisement we would see
true successors to the king or a
luminary step forward not the pretenders
in place today who have turned a
movement into an industry if not a
racket and just second on reading the
rest of what Jason Riley has to say
because I think this is true or to why
America celebrates Martin Luther King
that anything left is saying about
Martin Luther King today attempting to
rally Martin Luther King's support base
in popularity in favor of Bernie Sanders
Kamala Harris agenda first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Indo
Chino so yeah I used to get suits just
off the rack that was the way that I got
suits no longer now I get the best suit
I can find and that means a
made-to-measure suit from Indo Chino
it's the world's largest made-to-measure
menswear company Indo Chino has been
featured in major publications including
GQ Forbes and Fast Company they make
suits and shirts made to your exact
measurements for a great fit guys love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including your lapel
lining and monogram so here's how it
works you visit a showroom or you shop
online in indochina comm you pick your
fabric you choose your customizations
you submit your measurements and then
you just wait for the custom suit to
arrive in just a few weeks by the way if
you go to the showroom it's a lot of fun
it really is I've been to the showroom
in Beverly Hills and it's just
spectacular you walk in they show you
all the different fits and all the
different all the different types of
suits all the different materials it
really is a blast and right now this
week my listeners can get any premium
Indo Chino suit for just 379 bucks at
Indo Chino comm when you enter promo
code Shapiro's at checkout
and that's Indo Chino calm and cert
promo code Shapiro at checkout you get
any premium suit for just 379 bucks and
free shipping that is 50% off the
regular price for a made to measure
premium suit the suit fits like the
glove it's just fantastic Indo Chino com
enter promo code Shapiro again any
premium Indo Chino suit for 379 bucks
look like James Bond look like a million
bucks but don't spend a million bucks go
to Indo Chino comm promo code Shapiro
check it out and also that lets them
know that we say you okay so as I say
Jason Riley of The Wall Street Journal
has I think the best piece on Martin
Luther King's legacy and where we stand
today the left has tried to seize MLK's
legacy and say that he was actually a
failure because America failed him in
reality America did not fail dr. Martin
Luther King America has done its best to
live up to his legacy okay so here that
doesn't mean that there's no racism in
the United States it does mean that to
pretend that there has not been
unbelievable progress and that racism is
a fringe element in the United
States right now is to ignore reality so
Jason Riley says racial gaps that were
steadily narrowing in the 1940s 50s and
60s would expand in the 1970s 80s and
90s which suggests that the disparities
that continue today aren't being driven
by racism notwithstanding claims to the
contrary from liberals and their allies
in the media it also suggests that
attitudes toward marriage education work
and the rule of law play much larger
role than the left ones to acknowledge
more marches won't address out of
wedlock trial barren more sit-ins won't
lower black crime rates or narrow the
school achievement gap even electing and
appointing more black officials which
has been a major priority for civil
rights leaders over the past
half-century can't compensate for these
cultural deficiencies black mayors
police chiefs and school superintendents
have been commonplace since the 1970s
including in major cities with large
black populations racially gerrymandered
voting districts have ensured the
election of blacks to Congress even the
election of a black president twice
failed to close the divide in many key
measures black-white differences in
poverty homeownership and incomes all
grew wider under President Obama
discussion of antisocial behavior in
poor black communities let alone the
possibility that it plays a significant
role in racial inequality has become
another casualty of the post 60 zerah
writes Jason Riley the black columnist
over at The Wall Street Journal
King and other black leaders at the time
spoke openly about the need for more
responsible behavior in poor black
communities after a marking on a
disproportionately high inner-city crime
rate King told a black congregation in
st. Louis quote we've got to do
something about our moral standards he
added quote we know there are many
things wrong in the white world but
there are many things wrong in the black
world too we can't on keep blaming the
white man there are things we must do
for ourselves King's successors mostly
ignore this advice preferring instead to
keep the onus on White's
where King tried to instill in young
people the importance of personal
responsibility and self-determination
notwithstanding racial barriers his
counterparts today spend more time
making excuses for counterproductive
behavior and dismissing criticism of it
as racist activists who long ago
abandoned King's colorblind standard
which was the basis for the landmark
civil rights laws enacted in the 1960s
tell black youths
today that they are victims first and
foremost a generation of blacks have
more opportunity than any previous
generation are being taught that America
offers them little more than
trigger-happy cops bigoted teachers and
bias employers it's not only incorrect
but it's King in a previous generation
of black leaders understood it's also
unhelpful the reason that I read all of
this from Jason Reilly's because this is
important part of dr. King's legacy the
important part is the part that we know
it is the part that we know it doesn't
mean we shouldn't study the rest of dr.
King's life and analyze how he
brilliantly used the power of media and
brilliantly brilliantly used the power
of social demonstration in order to push
his agenda we should do all of these
things
I'm all for a more well-rounded nuanced
picture of history but if we're going to
say what do we celebrate about dr.
Martin Luther King it is a colorblind
standard that the left today is in the
midst of rejecting rejecting wholesale
the intersectional ideology of the left
fully reject all of this the
intersectional ideology of the left
fully suggests that you cannot have a
colorblind society that dr. Martin
Luther King was in fact wrong that dr.
Martin Luther King was incorrect in his
assessment of his dream his dream itself
was a problem and I present his evidence
to you an article by a by a professor
named kimberlé crenshaw whose executive
director of the African American Policy
Forum and a professor of law at Columbia
University she is also the inventor of
the concept of intersectionality and in
the column that she wrote for the
Washington Post I think as a couple
years ago she explained that
intersectionality isn't only supposed to
be a way of descriptive of describing
different experiences based on group
identity it's not just supposed to be
the Democrats are saying yeah black
people have one kind of experience and
white people have another kind of
experience instead intersectionality
which is what the Democratic Party
pushes is supposed to be a way of
promoting a leftist political agenda she
writes in The Washington Post quote
intersectionality was my attempt to make
feminism anti-racist activism and
anti-discrimination law do what I
thought they should highlight the
multiple avenues through which racial
and gender oppression were experienced
so that the problems would be easier to
discuss and understand so what does she
mean by this she means that the legacy
of America is racist and that there is
no way to overcome that white privilege
means we can never overcome this even if
every white person in America were to
acknowledge quote-unquote white
privilege and suggest that the system is
built for them they would still not have
anything to say because even then there
are certain racist bones in the white
body that cannot be overcome Haidee
there are literally colleges that are
teaching kids that if they say I am
colorblind this is an elements of racism
if you say I don't judge people based on
color this is a microaggression I am NOT
kidding this is something that is said
at universities across the land that is
a direct rejection of dr. King's dream
so what is the left doing they're saying
well really dr. King's dream wasn't the
colorblind society that was a bunch of
sloganeering for the cameras what his
dream really was was racial separatism
and competing interest groups his real
dream was the Bernie Sanders socialist
agenda that would overcome race with
redistribution ISM he's really a class
warrior rather than a warrior in favor
of racial integration this is not why
America celebrates dr. Martin Luther
King and to pretend otherwise is I think
a bit of nasty revisionist history that
has some pretty serious consequences for
the future of the country
okay well meanwhile speaking of
political polarization pushed by the
left you can see that the left is not
interested in the sort of integration in
the sort of peaceful talking that Martin
Luther King was attempting to push one
of the people who is supposedly a
successor to Reverend King reven dr.
King is Al Sharpton this is just it just
demonstrates the fall-off in the level
of political discourse and the level of
racial leadership that al Sharpton is
considered anywhere akin to Martin
Luther King it's just insane al Sharpton
is a race hustler al Sharpton has made
himself a fortune by blackmailing
companies by calling them racist al
Sharpton is a guy who has twice helped
initiate violence against Jews al
Sharpton is is just the scum of the
earth he's the scum of the earth al
Sharpton and yet here he is talking
about Martin Luther King and talking
about how Donald Trump has made racial
intolerance vogue again despite the fact
that al Sharpton legitimately called
white people's white called Jews white
interlopers in Harlem and suggested that
diamond merchants in New York were
responsible for killing black children
like hey al Sharpton is the worst of the
worst and here he is talk about how
Trump has made racial intolerance in
vogue again I think what people really
don't understand for thus those of us
that grew up in the King movement and
the generation after King is that we
mark the 50th anniversary with the
challenges that we have a president that
has made this kind of racial divide and
intolerant ah lurancy
become vogue again because when you look
at what Donald Trump is doing around pet
questions of people of color Mexicans
well
Muslim he has reintroduced with dr.
King's life was again taking us back
taking us really okay so yeah again
here's the problem I'm not fond of a lot
of trumps rhetoric I was very critical
of President Trump's response to
Charlottesville which I thought was
egregious during the election cycle I
thought that his response to questions
about the KKK was just awful I think
President Trump has a nasty habit of
saying things that are that are really
inflammatory about race and that is not
a good thing but to suggest that Trump
is the one who's responsible for the
racial uptick the uptick in racial
animosity in the country is not to say
it's not supported by data it's just not
if you look at moods about race in the
United States they were at an all-time
high by the time george w bush left
office and then if you look at mood
about race with regard to with regard to
divides between the races it jumped as
soon as obama took office and it
continued to grow well the president was
in office right and now Trump is taking
office and it hasn't narrowed and that's
not a shock because again when one side
embraces the idea that the colorblind
dream is no longer a dream but a
nightmare then you end up with racially
polarized society this sort of
polarization unfortunately has broken
out across the spectrum it's not just
with regard to race for example the it's
so bad that even normal politicians are
being attacked as in human just because
we disagree with them Ted Cruz I'm
friendly with senator Cruz and senator
Cruz the senator from Texas he was
campaigning in Texas the left is
celebrating this and this just
demonstrates how far our politics have
gone this woman walks up to Ted Cruz and
asks him if he is actually a human being
it's really it's really quite amazing
I'm not counting being female and a
survivor of abuse I purchased my
individual policy on the health
insurance extreme
either bankrupt me or tell me
I think this registered medical
depression personally and seriously and
I can assure you I'm not the only
petrified ooh my question is DNA and
it's a great response by senator Cruz
you can stop it there but that question
will you take a DNA test to prove that
you're human in an era of political
polarization let's just note that this
is not coming just from Donald Trump or
just from one side it sound good when it
does come from Trump I've ripped it when
it comes from Trump but it's coming from
both sides and it precedes president
Trump's presidency by a long way
speaking of that political polarization
in just a second
I'm gonna get to the worst political
polarization of the day and I want to
talk a little bit about these scandals
suppose it scandal surrounding EPA chief
Scott Pruett first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at
Chappaquiddick so as I have said before
they're sponsoring us to talk about
Chappaquiddick on this program it would
not matter I would still be talking
about Chappaquiddick on this program you
must go see Chappaquiddick it is in
theaters tomorrow you have a moral
obligation my listeners to go see
Chappaquiddick the reason for this is
because it took 50 years 5-0 years to
make a movie about a sitting senator of
the united states the scion of the most
famous family in the history of american
politics who literally left a woman to
drown in negligent homicide old-fashion
left or not even the drown but to die
suffocating in an air bubble that was
still present at the top of her car all
he has do is walk 50 feet pick up a
phone and call the cops instead afraid
of the blowback he left her to die at
the bottom of a river hey and this this
movie actually handles the issue but it
handles the issue with grace so the
movie does not suggest for example that
that Ted Kennedy was having an affair
with Mary Jo Kopechne me because there's
not the evidence to prove that it
doesn't suggest that she was pregnant
because there's not the evidence to
prove it they stick to the actual facts
of the case when they make
Chappaquiddick the it's also a really
nuanced well rounded picture of who Ted
Kennedy was so it's not a right-wing hit
job but it is also not an ode to Ted
Kennedy by any stretch of the
imagination the man comes off pretty
horribly as well he should when you
leave a woman to die at the bottom of a
river
Chappaquiddick the movie is out tomorrow
go check it out please
i-it's well-acted jason clarke kate mara
Edie Helms Jim Gaffigan Bruce Stern
terrific cast you're not gonna want to
miss this untold story of how one of the
one of the most covered up crimes in
American history saved the career of a
of a senator in Massachusetts
Chappaquiddick in theaters everywhere it
will suck up to the 6th look at the true
legacy of Ted Kennedy by going and
seeing it all right so let me talk a
little bit more about the political
polarization between right and left and
some insane comments from a Hollywood
director in just second but you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
the subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of Andrew Clavin
show live you get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live you also get the the
conversation so the conversation is the
Q&A that we do with our various hosts
and the next one is coming up next
Tuesday April 10th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific if you haven't yet
joined the conversation series it's our
monthly QA hosted by Alicia Kraus where
we answer any and all questions from
politics to the personal and this month
episode again features drew and it will
stream live on The Daily wires YouTube
page and as well as Facebook pages
everyone can watch it but if you want to
ask a question you have to subscribe so
go over to daily wire comm subscribe
type into the chat box ask your
questions and andrew Clavin will answer
those questions for an entire hour next
Tuesday April 10 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
with your annual subscription you get
all of those glories Plus you also get
something incredible you get the leftist
tears Hut or cold tumblr now the leftist
cheers however climate is just it's
phenomenal you will love it it's
incredible so go check it out again
please subscribe also because it helps
support the show and make sure we can
bring it to you every day I get that
annual subscription and help us out I
get lots of letters asking how you can
help us out that's the way it can help
us out is by subscribing really
appreciate it
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative show in the nation
[Music]
all right now speaking of political
polarization joss whedon is a director
he has not made a good movie in a little
while I know that everybody loves the
Avengers I'm not I'm not a huge fan in
any case Joss Whedon tweeted this out
yesterday just shows you where
Hollywood's head is he had quote Donald
Trump is killing this country some of it
quickly some slowly but he spoils and
destroys everything he touches him
Boldin's monsters wielding guns
governmental power or just smug
doublespeak or Russia my hate and
sadness are exhausting died on just
quietly die okay so I assume the Secret
Service will be paying a visit to Joss
Whedon's house because that is not
mentally healthy activity but it is
amazing how Trump's ascent has really
driven the left out of their ever-loving
mind I mean it really is an incredible
thing and again it demonstrates that I
think a lot of this was lurking under
the surface I think there's a crisis of
meaning that's happened in this country
I think the civil rights movement was
the culmination of a great American
moral move toward decency and I think
that there's a solid case to be made
that since about nineteen 19 1980 1984
the United States has been heading in
directly the wrong direction morally and
it's been in a continual downward spiral
punctuated by bursts of bursts of light
every so often immediately after 9/11
for example but the level of political
polarization in our society has grown to
such tremendous extremes that I'm not
sure that unity is even possible Martin
Luther King's dream wasn't just a
multiracial unity in the United States
who is of American unity toward a common
goal and we may have disagreed on some
of those goals particularly on economics
but we certainly didn't disagree on the
goals of a common society in which we
share certain inalienable rights I think
that has gone by the wayside because
everybody views their political opponent
as evil I don't think Joss Whedon is
evil I think Joss Whedon is stupid
I think Joss Whedon is consumed with his
hatred for people on the other side of
the aisle and this is just the latest
evidence of that okay meanwhile speaking
of what looks to be kind of scandal that
is being ginned up Scott Pruett is is
the head of the EPA he's been doing a
very effective job over at the EPA
getting rid of burdensome environmental
regulations the left really despises
Scott Pruitt in a major way and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who's the press
secretary was grilled about Scott Pruett
the left is calling for him to be
because of what they're calling
sweetheart deals I'll explain to you why
these charges are at the very least
overblown until we have all of the
evidence here as Sarah Huckabee Sanders
grilling skub being grilled by by the
press on unproven to head of the EPA my
questions have to do with another of a
sweetheart deal that's $50 a night
payment that the EPA Administrator scott
pruett
takes to a paid to a lobbyist that did
business with the EPA as you know Sarah
the president promised to drain the
swamp his behaviors actually seem very
swamp like why is the president okay
with us the president's not we're
reviewing this situation we have had a
chance to have a deeper dive on it we'll
let you know the outcomes of that but
we're currently reviewing that here at
the White House the president thinks
that he's done a good job particularly
on the deregulation front but again we
take this seriously and we're looking
into it we'll let you know okay so you
know this is about all she can say at
this point because not all the
information has come out apparently the
White House is somewhat unhappy with
Pruit because of all these supposed
scandals that are in the making one of
those scandals is that he supposedly
ends it around the process to give a
couple of his employees pay raises and
and scott pruett i said he didn't know
about those pay raises until yesterday
and he changed it suffice it to say that
a lot of this is being somewhat
overblown Molly Hemingway has a very
good piece over at the Federalist
talking about all the various things
that Scott Pruett was supposedly
supposed to have done wrong here it is
shall we say rather unclear that
anything wrong actually happened here so
he rented a room and who's approved for
the room by an 18-year career ethics
person at the EPA so no evidence of
wrongdoing yet and then apparently poor
would supposedly bypassed the White
House to get raises for a couple of his
top aides who came to DC from Oklahoma
and he didn't get White House approval
he says that he didn't even know about
it
so maybe that's true and then apparently
he flew first class because of security
threats which would not be a shock I fly
first class sometimes because of
security threats all of this is supposed
to be a rip I'm Scott Pruett let's just
say let's wait for the evidence Scott
Pruett is one of the top members of the
administration on the left hit list and
there's a reason that he's being
targeted okay so in just a second I want
to get to some things I
like and some things that I hate in fact
you know what let's just jump right into
it so time for some things I like and
time for some things that I hate so
things I like in honor of Martin Luther
King's the assassination of dr. King I
want to talk a little bit about Uncle
Tom's Cabin so this is a classic novel
people have taken it in all the wrong
ways in their interpretation of it over
the last century they've suggested that
even the term Uncle Tom has become a
term of derision about black people who
are supposedly too conciliatory with
white people right larry elder has been
called an Uncle Tom Jason Riley who I
read earlier has been called an Uncle
Tom Clarence Thomas has been called an
Uncle Tom if you read the book the point
of Uncle Tom's character is that he is a
christ-like figure right the whole point
is that he suffers so that he can help
other black folks be free and then he
suffers to bring people together that is
the entire purpose of his character it's
to better everyone around him when you
read the book on Uncle Tom's Cabin this
book was very very instrumental in
launching the Civil War because written
in 1852 it was a massive bestseller in
the first year following his publication
it was about 300,000 copies were sold in
the time when there weren't that many
people in the United States pretty
amazing number and this book was the
Bible of the abolitionist movement right
it was used as the Bible of the
abolitionist movement now they're a
bunch of folks now criticize it because
there are characters who they term a
mammy or a you know people
who are that there were their versions
that were staged of Uncle Tom's Cabin
there were much more derogatory to our
black people that Uncle Tom's Cabin
actually is but you failed to recognize
what Uncle Tom's Cabin did in its time
as a movement for black freedom that it
made a an unquestioning moral statement
that slavery was a grand and great evil
perpetrated by evil folks and that the
way to cure yourself of that evil was by
freeing your slaves and ending slavery
itself that was the message of the book
and so read the book you have your own
opinion on it for sure but recognize
that in the historical time in place
that it was written it was an
abolitionist statement of grand design
and it had a massive impact on the minds
of literally millions of people across
the United States okay time for a couple
of things that I hate
all right so a couple of things that are
pretty amazing that we need to talk
about so first thing that we need to
talk about is this comedian so there's a
woman a female comedian who I'd never
heard of until she started tweeting this
her name is Nikki Glaser and she tweeted
something out that she surely thought
was clever and snarky at Donald Trump
and his ex-wife so the couple was
recently divorced but they appeared at
the White House Easter egg hunt with
their five kids and Nikki Glaser
responded like this quote Tom jr. and
his wife have five kids all caps five no
one should be having five kids why are
people still allowed to have five kids
so President Trump is the fascist not
the left right the left actually
tweeting out things like why are people
still allowed too high of five kids
that's totally fine not a problem after
being called out on it of course Nikki
Glaser deleted but they're a bunch of
folks on the Left who actually think
this I'm talking about amanda marcotte
amanda marcotte so feminist author and
she wrote quote imagine if some woman
was like here are my eleven cats she was
talking about the I'm trying to remember
which which family she was talking about
there's a fellow who tweeted at Jill
philipovich another feminist Joe
philipovich had tweeted quote having
children is one of the worst things you
can do for the planet have one lesson
conserve resources and feminist authors
really doing their best to make
themselves popular and Patrick Madrid
who is a Catholic radio host he's
tweeted out dear Jill philipovich my
wife and I have 11 healthy happy and
successful children which one of them is
the world is one of the worst things for
the planet and this prompted amanda
marcotte to tweet quote imagine if some
woman was like kara my eleven cats when
we think her saying praise her
generosity nope we would be disturbed
well number one children are not cats no
matter how much feminists wish they
would be that that cat is not a child
okay that's just you if you have 11 cats
or a loser if you have 11 children
decent shot or a pretty decent life
success you're living in a religious
community I know and the rabbi who
taught me for my bar mitzvah had 15
children virtually all of his 15
children had 15 children she had
literally hundreds of grandchildren and
ticked off the left two to no end but
here's one of the things that's amazing
so there seems to be this feeling among
folks and leftist feminist circles that
if a woman chooses to have lots of kids
she's undermining her own happiness that
they see this picture in their head of
woman out on the Prairie with a bunch of
little urchins plucking at her garments
and she's they're taking the cloth
diapers and washing them in the
scrubbing bin and that's that's what she
does every day okay that's not the
actual truth you know what polls show
there's kind of an amazing thing
what polls actually show is that large
families aren't just fine they are
awesome the survey of marital generosity
found that parents of large families are
actually happier than parents of small
families isn't that amazing finding so
they found is either don't have any kids
at all or have lots of kids I don't have
like one kid have like four kids right
done which is what we intend on doing we
intend on having at least four children
and just to tick off the feminists I may
make it five so the and again my wife is
fine with that she's more feminist than
any of these feminists as I have said
you may know she is a doctor so my wife
is perfectly fine with working she likes
working and she's also intent on having
lots of kids which is a wonderful thing
but the left despises the creation of
new children because they feel the
children enslave women to their
reproductive organs okay the reality of
the situation is that children are the
greatest thing on planet earth they are
amazing and women being able to have
children is like a superpower
it's a superpower you generate another
human being out of your body and then
you feed it with your body and then the
baby grows up into a giant human that's
like an amazing amazing thing and for
all of these feminists to be taking the
thing that is most unique about the
female body right which is the ability
to produce children to take that and to
cast that out as something bad seems to
be profoundly anti feminine and
something seems to be profound high anti
female having lots of kids is just fine
okay if you can take care of your kids
and I'm not taking care of your kids go
for it right and this isn't this is my
feeling about kids if you can afford
your kids have as many as you want
okay other stupid things that the left
has been doing it's pretty amazing the
creator of Will & Grace which is the
most overrated show in the history of
television it never was a top ten show
it was it was never a massive ratings
success but it was boosted by the
critics because it was about gay folks
well the creator of Will & Grace is now
going to stick it to Vice President Mike
Pence by donating John Oliver's
mean-spirited gay bunny book to Indiana
schools so John Oliver wrote this book
that was supposed to rip Mike Pence's
daughter right but Mike finds his
daughter Charlotte wrote a children's
book about their bunny
it would just called Marlin bundo that's
the name of the punty and they wrote a
book
that china Oliver then wrote a book
about a gay bunny to try and slap it
pence
so naturally the creator of Will & Grace
is now going to send the book about the
gay bunny to Indiana schools because
that's just what children need to be
reading about is about bunnies with
particular sexual proclivities it's just
amazing how insane the left is that they
feel like school children need to be
reading about homosexual animals that's
that that's that's really the the thing
that kids need to be not reading writing
arithmetic you know decent social values
what they really need to be learning
about is where gay bunnies like to put
their penises like I'm just I'm so
confused by all of this but you know I
guess that's the way the left is is
thinking now I go back to Martin Luther
King leftists please and look at what he
did to unify the country and worry that
maybe you're not using the same tactics
okay so we will be back here tomorrow
and we have many things to discuss
tomorrow some breaking news on stormy
Daniels's lawyer we also are going to
give you some news about the Moller
investigation but we will see you then
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing